ian rappaport nfl network 27 minutes ago
tweeted uh the cowboys not expected to
be one of the teams vying for earl so
the cowboys thomas love affair ends here
for the record you're not confirming
that report to be true before we move on
exactly he doesn't know what he's
talking about
he has no what he's talking about
okay the only one that knows that is me
he's standing right here
that's jerry jones talking about one of
his employees at least 132nd of an
employee because the owner's own nfl
network so that was a little awkward to
say the least but jerry jones said it
that implies you know it shows that you
know you talked about the question in
the first segment right about you know
maybe
that just showed you that there was a
conversation before they came on air he
already knew he was going to rebuttal
the ian rappaport thing so i don't know
just
stood out to me sorry about that you're
right no you're right that one stood out
even more glaringly that was a good
catch by you and that further confirms
that maybe all the topics were headed
right ahead of time with suggested
questions for jerry jones and look when
you're jerry jones if that's what you
want obviously that's what you get and
105 3 the fan in dallas not going to
blink not going to push back not going
to do anything that keeps them from
having jerry jones on their station
twice a week because every time he's on
he makes news and the news yesterday
that the cowboys according to jones
himself not necessarily closing the door
and why would you close the door on
anybody why would you right why do it
there's no reason there's no reason to
slam the door and nail it shut unless
it's just someone who is flat out
contemptible and you're trying to send
the message that you want nothing to do
with that human being other than that
you there's no reason there's no reason
to tell the world that you're not going
to do it and you never know what's going
to happen you could lose all your
safeties to injury that day and there
could be no one else out there that you
can sign and maybe you can get earl
thomas for a steal right because he
wants to play for you and he's otherwise
not getting any interest so why would
you slam the door chris i i'm with you
and it did feel like it was something
that was specifically set up and and uh
jerry jones knocked it down yeah he
knocked it down you know this is a guy
that he's obviously you know had his eye
on for quite some time so i'd be shocked
if he just shut the door on that
conversation we've heard earl thomas of
the dallas cowboys for the last what two
years three years at least right we've
heard that kind of talk so uh obviously
there's some common love there
but the the big thing is and why i don't
think you also can slam the door shut is
you know if you look at the cowboys
roster safety's probably one of the
bigger questions there is you know who
are going to be the two safeties you
know xavier woods he's a little bit like
an earl thomas a smaller guy who can fly
around the field and throws his body
around right but who is gonna be that
other guy is it ha ha clinton dicks you
know is it darion thompson i don't know
either one of those you know
they're not like star-studded oh i feel
good you know there are starting
safeties they're one of the best in the
league no they're not that type of guy
they're you know they're they're in the
lower class of safeties those two guys
so does does earl thomas is he better
than them
you know yeah maybe he is so but the
price is going to be the price is going
to be i think the the end of that
conversation what is earl going to want
will he be willing to maybe take a
little less to go there do that do the
cowboys have some guys at the corner
position that maybe they can move to
safety i don't know but it is one
position you look at it in their team
and go hey
it's not the best uh as compared to the
rest of the roster which is very
impressive
well it falls into the we'll see what
happens category for earl thomas the
cowboys earl thomas and anyone else and
we're into day three now of him being
available and there hasn't been any firm
link between him and a new team and i
think any team that is even remotely
interested realizes the thing to do at
this point is let it simmer let it stew
and if you are
truly interested you get a lot of
homework to do what happened in seattle
what happened in baltimore and how do i
avoid that from happening here and one
way to avoid it from happening give earl
thomas time to become humbled and to
become maybe a little desperate a little
bit of that cam newton attitude where
you think that the game is passing you
by and you're being left yeah on the
side of the road and that may be the
thing that affects the kind of change
necessary to get earl thomas back to
being
the kind of player and teammate that he
once was well agreed that that's got to
happen because the play is not at a
level that's where you can accept that
type of behavior off the field anymore
you know hey
this is i you know i had some arguments
on social media about this yesterday and
stuff with people if earl thomas was
still one of the five best safeties or
10 best safeties in football he'd
already be on a team he'd it would
already happen when you're that good you
know his laundry list of issues isn't
long enough to where they like oh i
don't know you know like antonio brown
didn't even make the raiders or the
patriots blink so his laundry he had a
way bigger list
but but people could accept that because
he was definitely in the conversation
for one of the top five receivers in
football so that's where it's different
here and i know earl thomas has been
such a household name and he's a hall of
famer and a legend and all those type of
way all those things not trying to but
like people are acting right now like
how could he be free how could no team
want him and just sign him immediately
because when you turn on the film it
doesn't match what the guy was making
and then like you said to be kicked off
a team or what pete carroll said that
ain't a bad look that's about as bad as
it gets for a football player in the nfl
so that is going to cause some
trepidation
yeah other than jerry jones going out of
his way to make sure the door is still
slightly ajar at best in dallas what
we've seen and heard in recent days
coaches saying
we're good we're good with who we have
you got kyle shanahan said that
yesterday and my guess is richard
sherman behind the scenes maybe trying
to lobby a little bit for earl thomas if
he was genuine in his tweet when earl
thomas was let go by the ravens and
maybe want to get the gang back together
again half of the legion of boom
whatever the case may be didn't work
kyle's not interested they're good with
who they have and that's what we're
hearing we're not hearing well we'll
look at it we'll talk about it we'll see
we're hearing no thanks we're ready to
move on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports